what we're trying to solve at swim is a
way to easily
download this knowledge download this
information that is in the head of the
developers and create a
strong knowledge base around the code
that will actually grow
as the code is growing and not something
that will be you know this kind of like
line that is uh going down every time a
developer leaves and some of the
knowledge lives with the developer we
want to create something that is growing
together with the code
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today i am with oren toradano the ceo
and co-founder of swim making continuous
documentation an integral part of the
development life cycle
an accomplished leader in the high-tech
industry oren has led numerous
international technological training
hubs over the past 10 years including
co-founding israel tech challenge in
2012 and serving as the ceo until 2019.
oren has a bachelor's of arts in
political science from the hebrew
university and a masters in security
studies from the tel aviv university
[Music]
you know it's
personal career you know it's a
phenomenal you know and amazing
different things that you've done from
being a major in the intelligence forces
to
working in different organizations being
the ceo and co-founder of israel tech
challenge which
as i just explained before we started
recording holds a very dear place in my
heart and i'm very thankful for this
program
and just as interesting if not more is
your most recent adventure swim um with
with some amazing announcements for for
an amazing series a and then some great
investors on board uh some of them are
great great friends and as a developer
myself
sort of understanding you know where
where you're coming from and and how
you're helping you know me sort of solve
my own issues with how i operate as a
developer and i can then extrapolate to
others and so you know a lot of
different things to dive into and oh and
i really want to thank you for coming
here share with me a little bit about
yourself because you're you're a founder
of the various organizations are you an
engineer a an entrepreneur founder well
how do you think yourself so maybe you
will notice in the accent uh originally
i was born in france and uh
grew up there until the age of 17.
moved to israel
learned hebrew
studied political science and economics
at the hebrew university of jerusalem
and had the chance to be selected for
and that's how
my
path with technology started
but i served there for eight years in
different positions as you said as
eventually as a major
uh in in the part that is more
operational and and the intelligence
part of the of the unit
and so that's where i got my knowledge
with you know technology product
um and connecting between the needs or a
pain or a need for a solution and the
engineering part of of that and i think
as the ceo right now the ability to
balance between the need of a client and
the technological uh specs is something
that uh
is important
after this period in the
army i was three years in france i was
the head of the jewish agency for uh for
france in belgium
so like personal
things that i wanted to uh to do and
then i came back founded as you said
israel tech challenge itc
um was the ceo for seven years
and that's another
layer of understanding technology
understanding the need for human
resource
we've been talking a lot these last two
years in israel
kind of like
discovered the problem of
of shortage for developers early on
and try to solve that through itc um and
and also through my experience at idc
kind of like got to swim and we will get
there later
but so it's about training technology
coding
zionism kind of thing
connection with israel
so that's that's my background fantastic
and so this there's you know the element
of of
identifying a gap in the market and a
need both from a human resource
perspective but also from a personality
perspective bridging together
zionism your own aliyah your own journey
with the agency but also on a personal
level through you know coming to israel
in the into the army but then bridging
it into engineering and into the actual
ecosystem and uh did you even know how
many how many engineers you've brought
into
the ecosystem so sometimes i like
counting although
it might be a bit problematic but so
there are two numbers that i like to
hold for myself one is the hundreds of
engineers that i think almost more than
one thousand right now after all these
years with itc
uh so i think it's kind of
a real personal um um joy uh it's kind
of crazy part of this it's kind of it's
kind of insane you know
creating a school that actually created
almost if not more than a thousand
engineers in tv ecosystem this is not
trivial it's not simple and as as many
entrepreneurial journeys it takes time
until you get there uh and a lot of
effort uh and another number that i like
is from my period that the jewish agency
is like six thousand jews that came to
israel during this time so all together
i think i did my zionist part for the
country and i'm happy to do like more
business right now
but yeah i love it those numbers are i'm
very proud of
incredible so
you know take me back to the founding of
swim because
you know you're touching on you know
you're you're in a similar problem space
you know you're talking about the way
that developers are working more
importantly how they're helping onboard
and document for the new hires and their
colleagues and for themselves
you know what what is sort of your
understanding of the problem space as
your thinking through swim
yeah it actually came from israel tech
challenge because we were training uh so
many people to become developers or to
improve themselves in becoming data
scientists or cyber security researchers
and then
we understood that it was a big pain for
them to onboard in their new jobs and we
also understood from the companies
themselves that
it was a big effort
you know for all what's related with
what we call engineering boarding
um and me and my co-founders try to
understand where the pain exists exactly
and we met with many companies uh in
israel and in the us and we understood
that there is at the is the essence of
this problem is
understanding the code base right
understanding the code at this of the
company and each company has its own
stack its own technologies it's its own
logic and there is no uh
dev tool there is no technology that is
built right now
uh to help ramp up engineers so that's
how it started from the onboarding
problem of developers and then
eventually just to clarify because i
think it's it's an it is an important
clarification yeah if i you know i'm if
somebody who's not who's not necessarily
an engineer now thinks through this
problem they're thinking okay you know
let's let's equate a repository to a
google drive folder and you have a bunch
you have a table of contents and you
have a bunch of files and you know you
just you just go ahead and print them
out and and just start reading them and
you'll understand the thesis and and the
logic but but it's a little different
than that and right so in what way yeah
code is very complex um it has been uh
usually when you join a company that is
you know more than 10 developers already
has been written by many developers in
different ways
and usually with a kind of like complex
logic behind it
and it's not self-explanatory i mean
some parts of the code are and if you
read code you can understand parts of it
but you can't understand the complex
logic behind it the different flows and
how things were
exactly built and then when you have to
contribute code and you have to write a
feature or you have to solve a bug uh
it's kind of like complicated and the
way it's done right now is that you ask
your fellow developers in the companies
and some of them already left right so
there is what we call legacy code in
many in many companies uh there are
areas in the repo in the code base that
nobody really understands and kind of
like
try to avoid because of uh of the
complexity of it yeah and results in
like in years of like technological debt
and and a lot of challenges for
companies and we're kind of trying to
solve that
makes a lot of sense and so
when we go back to this question of
complexity
what you know what what makes it complex
in your mind is it simply that that
coding is complex that engineering is
complex or is it the the habits that we
formed
that are that make it complex
yeah it's a good it's a good question i
think it's it's a mix as you know many
things it's the fact that code is is a
complex creation right
and as uh it becomes more and more
advanced uh it becomes more and more
complex so you have like microservices
and
all kind of like additional technologies
and and third-party libraries you're
adding so it becomes this like very
complex and beautiful creation
but also very difficult to uh to explain
right um and as you said another part of
that is that we didn't have the tools or
the the good habits to create
um
a knowledge base around the code base
itself so you have all this code that is
being written and and you know that the
developers are are in shortage so you
don't want them to do too much that is
not coding uh so every time they write a
line of code they can't
actually document this code and can
can't explain it but
you know the the result of that is every
time someone needs to understand the
code that actually needs the they need
the developers themselves to explain it
but you know it's kind of like a messy
situation at the end of the day where uh
the knowledge is very scattered in
different places in the head of the
developers and there is no good way to
download all this information that is in
the heads of many developers some of
them as i said already left the
companies and to make it something that
you can easily understand and and you
can easily
contribute as a result of of getting to
this information getting to this
knowledge
so what we are trying to solve at swim
is a way to easily
download this knowledge download this
information that is in the head of the
developers and create a
strong knowledge base around the code
that will actually grow
as the code is growing and not something
that will
be you know this kind of like line that
is
going down every time a developer leaves
and some of the knowledge leaves with
the developer we want to create
something that is growing together with
the code
so once again we're tying together
the the educational piece of it the best
habits piece of it
and then the and then the whole a larger
question of cons of of behavior of
engineers and how do you actually create
a product that's sticky for engineers to
to write the documentation to contribute
to it sure and how do we make it
informative and educational for those
that are receiving it
right and so you're you're you're you're
again you're you're playing with this
with similar sides again with itc which
which i still i find fascinating you
know the
the progression of understanding uh here
and how you're implementing it tell me a
little bit about the product well how
does sure sure
so
yeah so when we started learning about
you know what is documentation you know
it's something that developers hate uh
because they usually it's like overhead
for them to write documentation so they
have
i think three main pains that we
discovered uh while doing that it's like
it's hard to write documentation
it's hard to maintain documentation
because the code is changing all the
time so as you are writing documentation
it becomes obsolete very quickly and
also it's very hard to find
documentation in time when you need it
uh as you said it's the google drive so
let's do the right search to find the
right docs or whatever and most people
just give up and the fact that they're
they have all these issues make the the
you know the essence of writing
documentation uh really not appealing
because if i know that it's not is going
to be very quickly obsolete and nobody
will find it i don't want to write it
right it's kind of like i hate it uh so
what we're trying to rebuild here here
is this relationship between developers
and documentation so make it easy to
write easy to maintain and easy to find
and the way to do to do it is if you
know in our eyes in our opinion is to
connect it very deeply with the ci cd
with the workflow of the developers
making it um very um intuitive for
developers to write this documentation
and in some cases we will help them with
automated
documentation that we will create based
on patterns in the code itself
we will make it easy to maintain so we
will
connect the docs that we are creating
with swim with the code itself and we'll
be actively following after the changes
in the code and with our smart algorithm
we'll be able to say this doc is up to
is outdated we will update it
automatically for you or we will flag it
for you and you will update it
and because of this connection with the
code itself
while you are in the id in in the in the
environment of the developer environment
we will tell you exactly where doc is
relevant you know when you're working so
if you're working on this piece of code
we'll tell you
here in your id uh there is a doc that
is relevant and you will be able to read
it in your id so you we will try to
avoid a context switch which is a big
problem for developers
so it sounds like you you lay the
groundwork here to say you know we
understand fundamentally that we cannot
do context switching for engineers you
know part of it is that you know we like
things in the shell or in our ide we
don't want to transition to different
applications you're not going to find
engineers on slack for most of the day
because we don't want to do the the
command the command tab and and go to
different applications which makes sense
then you're saying we actually can
create a layer of technology that will
maintain the information of which docs
are relevant and up to date very similar
to how let's say npm makes sure that if
you install a package maybe it has
dependencies that are also not up to
date so we've already seen a model here
that works which makes a lot of sense
but then you said something interesting
about the the cicd process so i'm
curious about how do you get engineers
to contribute to this and you said that
that was a part of this icd is that an
enforcement mechanism
before they deploy and before they get
their feature out they have to
contribute to the documentation so
enforcement is a word that we don't
really like
but uh
but we but it's also right but it's kind
of like building a culture of
documentation right so um um once you
couple the code with the with the docs
uh you want to ensure that the work
you've done as a developer is not going
to go out of sync right so if it's part
of the build if it's part of the ci cd
um and you decide as a team to block
every time
a pr every time it goes out of sync so
it becomes this habit right you're
building these habits of making sure uh
the docs are up to date but in in many
cases in more than 90 of the cases swim
will update automatically the docks so
we'll make just sure it's another step
in in in the build that the dog stays um
stay up to date
but how do you actually cope with logic
changes i mean because how you have to
differentiate between semantic changes
yes plus
one more parameter one less parameter
versus okay there's actually a logic
change to how company x thinks about
entity y which which actually has a
butterfly effect that is pretty massive
so it's part of the or secret sauce and
the patent that swim has is
by adding snippets of codes in the doc
themselves and by looking at the
snippets and the contextual change and
uh the syntax change that happens around
the snippets we're able to decide
whether the changes were
important or
were just
you know changes that happen all the
time like
changes of names changes of lines or
whatever or even additions in the code
themselves but that don't change the
real
essence of the code so based on this
algorithm that analyzes these changes we
can decide whether to update the doc
automatically or tell the developer you
need to take a look at that because it's
outdated
that makes a lot of sense
swim is a company now so you you have
the product
strategies for
getting into the market
what how do you you know a little bit if
i go to market and sure sure how do you
actually get this to scale across every
organization potentially sure so um with
developers there is a playbook
that you may follow or not
but it has to be a plg approach at least
it has it needs to have a part of it
that is plg
product led growth
meaning that developers want to test the
product it's themselves they want to
make sure they like it
there is what we call developer
happiness so it needs to be it's really
like almost a bit to sear approach when
you need you know the approval of the
other developers so there is this motion
that we called bottom up and there is
another motion that we call top down and
more like a b2b sales practice that you
need to have with bigger organizations
because
for for the reasons of connecting the
docs with the code we need sometimes uh
some security process and an i.t process
and for some companies the bottom-up
approach won't work because they need
some approval and some process so you
need to have the two motions um going on
so you have like a marketing product
approach that for that works for plg and
you have like marketing sales approach
with a sales team that works top down
and work with usually more senior people
in the organizations
and i can imagine there's a few
different kpis that you can measure all
the way from how updated are the
documentation versus how many what
percentage of engineers are are engaging
with the documentation reading it or
writing it what is the what are the kpis
that you really
know what what is it well listen when
you're when you're a sas or and plg most
uh importantly you need to like measure
all parts of the funnel right so like uh
conversion from website to sign it and
then you need to measure adoption so how
do you measure your adoption how fast it
is to write a first doc
how fast people invite additional people
from the team how a team moves from one
team to two teams to three teams how
many dogs are being written how many
dogs are being ridden
are being read how many docks are being
maintained uh how many docs goes through
the ci process and and you know so all
this we measure and we see a
level of adoption number of users that
are interacting with the platform et
cetera et cetera and it's definitely a
land and expand motion so you start
usually with one team and then it grows
to another the fact that you are inside
the build inside the ci cd so everybody
sees you in github or whatever uh so
there is this um
this interesting uh challenge for a
product team and and it's a very very
product oriented uh
strategy
no and i think that the you know
something that's really fascinating
about this strategy is that that given
that you succeed here with with working
with a company and becoming a part of
the cicd process
the opportunities are pretty limitless
for you as a company because all of a
sudden you can find yourself as a swim
you know potentially as a series c
company transitioning from just helping
documentation to actually helping you
know make make sure that the code is
actually up to date with all the
packages in the outside world and best
practices you have visibility into the
best practices of engineers all over the
world and you can actually help
companies
be you know give help engineers become
better engineers through better habits
which is yeah you know and a lot of them
interesting things it i want to say
something that won't sound very humble
but sometimes you need to hear it from
you know outsiders so um we were raising
our series a and we met with one of the
important
investors in new york and then i met
them after after a while and they told
me you know the thing i heard from your
presentation about swim is that actually
you're building a better and smarter
atlassian and you know we didn't think
about that atlassian is you know one of
the biggest uh dev tool companies
dealing with you know also documentation
but also task management and also git
hostings etc so kind of like when you
own this knowledge on the code itself
and you're able to understand who does
what and how it's done and you know what
are the best practices from this
essence of the code you can go in many
many different
directions and i think it's it's
it's really
you know it's really something that
we're looking forward to yeah and the
organ really i am congratulations on on
the amazing accomplishments all around
and i the the thread here
to me it seems pretty clear you know how
you're taking
the learnings and experiences from each
experience and translating it and
advancing it to the next one and
obviously swim right place right time
incredible problem both from the hr
perspective but also from the
perspective of automations and how do
you how do you take the current hr that
you have and you make it scalable and
you make it as efficient as possible and
so i i i really love what you're doing
and
fascinating to hear a little bit through
your thought process and obviously we
can go on for hours but we have 20
minutes and it's true
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you have a good day thank you
[Music]
you